indeed Those who commit crime used to
laugh at those who believed Charlie
hebdo
brothers and sisters I have come
together with one ummah to raise funds
for the catastrophic earthquake that's
taking place in turkey and Syria please
donate whatever you can even if it's one
pound to save the people's lives
inshallah a scum newspaper which is
Charlie hebdo these people who
dehumanize Muslims yes and they hate our
Gods you ask these evil people who laugh
and mock at our dismay at times where
the whole world should support them no
matter how evil you might be but these
people are the evil of the evil and
Allah has a message for them
and the message that Charlie hebdo this
message gives me goosebumps
brothers and sisters listen to this and
I'm going to end the videos on this
inshallah may Allah Aid them and for the
enemies of Islam
bite your fingers like Allah out of Rage
they bite their fingers when they see
Islam spreading around the world
millions and billions of people coming
to Islam you will never ever ever defeat
Islam the light of Allah even though the
disbelievers hated like Allah says is
going to shine through no matter how
much this Believers hated and in this
verse Allah says brothers and sisters it
talks about these disbelievers who mock
the Believers guess what let them mock
us now for our belief and for us dying
can you imagine we have been mocked for
dying from sisters subhanallah check
this out Allah says
foreign
[Music]
indeed Those who commit crime used to
laugh at those who believed Charlie
hebdo and when they passed by them they
would exchange decisive glance
and when they return to their people
they would return jesting mocking you
see how we mock them and when they saw
them they would say indeed those are the
truly lost they used to say to the
Believers these people are lost people
yeah and this is the Ayah that I recited
but they had not been sent as Guardians
over them
so today those who believed are laughing
at the disbelievers this is the day of
judgment now they love to us mocked us
yes persecuted us now the tables have
turned today the Believers will laugh at
them but how Allah says on adult couches
observing the Believers will be on
couches and they would see the Sinners
being thrown into the Hellfire being
dragged into the Hell Fire because they
deserved it because they just deserved
it and we're talking about those hostile
enemies by the way yeah and guess what
the last word says and this and the
Believers will say have the disbelievers
have the disbelief is not being warned
for that for what they used to do
this is the message of your lord carry
on laughing like they say the one who
has the last laugh
will surely laugh the best
be firm or Believers and support your
brothers and sisters in turkey and Syria
with one ummah which I'm trying to raise
funds for assalamualaikum